c'est un souvenir celui d'une enfant de
4 ans raconté par une vieille dame
hantée par sa mémoire l'Europe était en
guerre l'Empire ottoman à l'agonie
assassin un peuple pour mieux devenir la
tur
c'est un récit celui de la mort d'une
mère tué par la
fin j'ai couru pour averter ma maman que
ils ont apporté à manger on doit avoir
faim je sais pas moi et ben quand je
suis arrivée ver devant la la porte
d'appartement ma mère il était allongée
par terre et moi je suis assise sur elle
je tappé je tapppé je voulais dire
lève-toi ils ont porté à manger avec
elle bouge pas les femmes il sont venu
oh il est
Mor
est le gnocide arménien c'est cette
souffrance exilée avec ses enfants d'Al
à beirouth de beirouth à Marseille puis
P Vienne Valence
dessine longtemps ce fut une souffrance
muette
elle s'est fait entendre à partir de
1965 d'abord dans la république
soviétique d'Arménie puis dans toute la
diaspora TR décennies de revendication
nont pas
suffi le peuple arménien attend toujours
la reconnaissance de son martyre il se
bat lui aussi contre ceux qui ni le
génocide pire il se bat contre l'oubli
qui progresse au sein même d'une Arménie
désormais
indépendante
et la Turquie joue un rôle on le sait
clairement en Bosnie joue un rôle
clairement on le sait en tchchenie par
un soutien direct et vous le savez aussi
que le problème des pétroles de
l'acheminement des pétroles qu'on vient
de trouver en mer Caspienne est un
problème stratégique économique mais
aussi politique en fonction de l'endroit
par où passera le léoduc donc on serait
très tenté aujourd'hui et nos
compatriotes nos frères d'Arménie qui
vivent che rappelle aujourd'hui dans des
conditions absolument dramatiques de
blocus de situation économique
impossible sociale politique et bien eux
même dans l'ordre de leur priorités
pourrai tenté de mettre au second plan C
cette ce souci de mémoir et les
pressions croyez-moi existent
directement
entre 1915 et 1923 les 2 tiers de la
population arménienne de Turquie ont été
massacré 80 ans plus tard la religion
chrétienne la langue et la mémoire de la
catastrophe constituent le ciment d'un
peuple dispersé mais au-delà de
l'identité arménienne la commémoration
du génocide garde un sens universel des
crimes contre l'humanité se commettent
toujours à la fin du 20e
siècle